wild weather
rages around the world these pictures
just a snapshot
of what's happened within the last 48
hours alone
now a landmark u.n climate report has
delivered
a confident and frightening verdict
human behaviour is unequivocally warming
our planet
driving many of these extreme conditions
the un says this is a code red for
humanity
and there is nowhere to hide in every
region in the world
climate and weather extremes have
changed because of human influence
and um this is particularly striking for
heat waves so heat waves have
increased in their frequency and
intensity
around the world and will also
continue to increase no matter
no matter if we stop warming at 1.5 or 2
or or higher degrees of warming
the intergovernmental panel on climate
change says that many of the
consequences of global warming
like rising sea levels are already
irreversible
but immediate dramatic cuts and
emissions could still help us avoid the
worst scenarios
that's exactly the aim of a crucial
climate summit being held in glasgow
later this year
called cop 26 viewed by many
as a last chance when you're negotiating
and you're trying to push countries to
do more how helpful is it to have this
really solid science behind you
it's critical it reduces any
ambiguity it it removes
any wiggle room underpinning everything
in in science
and providing solidly backed um
arguments and and statements is
absolutely essential in terms of
narrowing the conversation
to what needs to be done rather than
debating
whether we are at crisis point
excuses are vanishing but cop 26
is still in a precarious position
advisers directly involved in the
negotiations tell sky news that there is
now
a huge effort underway to resolve
sticking points that threaten the summit
mainly over how to phase out coal and
end fossil fuel subsidies
as host the uk government is feeling the
pressure
what practical concrete difference do
you believe that the ipcc report will
make
as you are pushing countries to do more
it's a wake-up call and i think people
should understand from this that unless
we get to grips
with climate change now uh humanity is
facing catastrophe
i i think it's as stark as that and
that's why
all countries need to come forward and
that's the message that i'm going to
continue to deliver
as i speak to governments around the
world
the un report could not have been
clearer about what is at stake
climate change does not respect borders
time
or the absence of global political will
the future of our planet depends on the
decisions our leaders
make now hannah thomas peter sky news